para el jefe de la diplomacia europea es
josep borrell ahora la máxima prioridad
para la Unión Europea es ayudar a
Ucrania y prueba de ellos por ejemplo
las dos decisiones que se han tomado hoy
para empezar la aprobación de una misión
de entrenamiento militar para soldados
ucranianos en un principio van a ser
15.000 soldados ucranianos que van a ser
formados en territorio europeo aunque se
espera que esta formación se ampliegue a
muchas más personas una misión que
empezará a partir de noviembre que
tendrá una duración máxima de dos años
por otra parte también se ha probado la
ayuda de 500 millones de euros más para
el fondo de envío de armas a Ucrania lo
que hace un monto total de más de 3000
millones de euros solo para armas para
Ucrania el secretario el jefe de la
diplomacia europea Jose asegura que
Vladimir Putin está perdiendo la guerra
en el terreno político y también moral
Pero que y que por eso está aumentando
también los ataques contra civil con
supuestos drones de fabricación iraní la
Unión Europea está estudiando intentando
recabar pruebas aunque los servicios de
inteligencia europeos y también las
autoridades ucranianas aseguran la
procedencia de Irán la Unión Europea
dice que de confirmarse va a actuar en
correspondencia